the first purge is here to confuse
everyone when you're talking about the
purge movies in the future and you say
you like the first purge and someone
asks you what do you mean the 2013 one
and you're like no no the prequel the
movie called the first purge and they're
like oh so this prequel tells us how the
purge came about how the law was passed
how it started originally on Staten
Island in just one place it was viewed
as an experiment and later became a
nationwide thing one night out of the
year for 12 hours there are no laws you
can get away with anything you want
including murder and people have to
survive just like all the other films
and I was actually interested in this
film the concept of how something like
this began was intriguing to me and I
could see that it could perhaps provide
a more interesting experience especially
with the social and political commentary
that this series has tried and reached
for and so I was actually interested to
see how they would approach this subject
matter because one of the issues I've
always had with the purge franchise is
that I just don't really buy into it and
so I wanted to see how they would
approach it and you know I was kind of
surprised to see that basically it
follows the exact same formula beat for
beat as all the other purge movies it's
just that right as this one starts you
see newsreel footage that tells us that
there's arguing going on and debates and
rallies and people are protesting about
this experiment and it's already in
motion
we don't actually see the the
progression of events that lead to it it
just begins with hey it's gonna happen
really soon just like all the other
purge films you meet your heroes the
people you're supposed to care about and
then the purge starts and really the
only major difference with the purge
sequences is that less people are killed
because people are still kind of
uncomfortable with it so there's less
carnage and less death and so I feel
like fans of this franchise aren't going
to be happy with that because this
franchise tries to be very political and
it tries to have a social message but in
the long run the people who go to see
this movie are people who want to see a
bunch of carnage and death and a horror
action movie that's all they want and
that's the only reason these movies make
their budget back because they're very
cheaply made and people enjoy going to
the theater and watching some carnage
for
an hour and a half this film tries and
reaches and reaches and reaches to have
a message and it's so heavy-handed and
so incredibly obvious that I didn't buy
into it for a minute one of the biggest
problems I have with this franchise is
I've already alluded to is that it's
trying to have a message it's trying to
have a moral that means something that
makes us think but it's sort of like the
fast-food version of that it's all
surface level it's all aesthetic there's
nothing under the surface and when it
comes to the protagonists in this film
we follow a hardcore drug dealer who
owns corners all around Staten Island
where he places people who distribute
his drugs and this is our main character
we're supposed to care about this person
who is sending drugs throughout the
population of Staten Island New York for
some reason this is the guy we're
supposed to follow what I'll say as the
lead actor is actually really good and I
would love to see him in other films I
think he has a great future he could
totally be a star but this character as
he's written on the page I didn't want
to root for him I didn't care about him
despite the film's attempt to have a
message it just never really impacted me
because it was very obvious that it's
just yet again another purge movie with
a bunch of action and horror scenes that
are supposed to be scary but they're
really honestly laughable the first act
actually had an okay set up Marisa Tomei
plays the orchestrator of this event I
was curious to see if they would go
deeper but they don't the set up was
initially intriguing but as soon as the
event starts it's just another purge
movie we have old ladies with a cart
filled with explosive teddy bears
when a woman is getting assaulted by
these guys on the purge night the scene
actually was getting kind of intense and
then they had to throw a line in there
that was just so on the nose and so
obvious to what it was referencing that
it just kind of ruined the entire scene
when our lead hero is with these two
women in a room it fades to black very
awkwardly and then just booms back on to
the screen and I honestly thought the
power went out for a second and I want
to talk about the technical aspects here
because there's some stuff I noticed
right off the bat the sound effects are
probably the cheapest most used stock
sound effects you could possibly hear I
recognized many of them from 1990s
do games that's how old some of them are
the CGI blood in particular is atrocious
there's a scene in the fog it looked
like a youtube skit it looked like
something I could achieve by just
downloading some effects from YouTube
using Final Cut Pro and just sort of
like masking out the background it was
so so obviously CGI and cheap there's a
choice with a character that's very
important to this film also to play a
scene with that character entirely
through security camera footage and it
just plays like they couldn't afford
this actor for another day so they just
used the security cam footage and so you
almost feel like you're missing
information characters make such idiotic
choices too our lead hero is underneath
the SUV hiding from some bullets that
are being fired from drones overhead he
sees a lot of his friends get killed and
then within two seconds after the last
round is fired he just emerges from
underneath the van looking around I'm
like dude you didn't wait even for a
second you're about to get killed dude
like look around at least check your
check your six check your front check
your sides whatever he doesn't because
the script doesn't ask him to do that
the first purge is a poor excuse to make
more money off of a franchise that
doesn't cost much to make because they
know they're gonna make it back within
the opening weekend alone one of the
most important aspects of a film like
this is the promise of your premise
really that's one of the most important
thing about any film is that the
audience goes in with expectations and
you have to at least address those
expectations or try to harness them in
some way or show them those expectations
in a different way my expectations going
in was that we were going to get a more
mature exploration of how this even
began and it's just another purge movie
I'm gonna give the first purge a d-plus
this is the first one on the franchise
that technically even just did not feel
like it was up to par with the rest the
effects the editing the sound effects
choices this could have been a lot
better even if it was just a throwaway
horror movie it could have been better
nevertheless guys thank you so much as
always for watching look forward to more
reviews very soon and if you like this
you can click right here and get stuck
mine eyes
[Music]